what started with a virus so small your
eyes couldn't see it this is about
providing future for humanity
the commission has decided to find
google
4.34 billion
[Music]
is euros man on the moon moment we are
innovating here and we hope that you
like it
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to europe calling a series of
podcasts brought to you by the european
commission looking at the politics and
policies of the union today with me
stephen jones and me paul anderson it's
good to be back with you stephen after
our short break thank you paul same here
today we're focusing on disability and
diversity in society in our communities
and in our workplaces
in case you didn't notice we've just
marked the international day of people
with disabilities and if you didn't
notice one reason may be that people
with disabilities are often marginalized
or forgotten and isolated within society
that's right paul and never more true
than during the pandemic and life during
and after the pandemic is the theme of
this year's international day
spearheading europe's drive to be a more
diverse equal and inclusive society is
helena dali commissioner for equality in
the european commission paul give us the
lowdown on her well she's a former
minister for social dialogue consumer
affairs and civil liberties in her
native malta she's also been since her
teenage years a passionate advocate and
campaigner on human rights and as we'll
discover later a huge fan of david bowie
a warm welcome to you commissioner and
to you our listeners too
commissioner with reference to the fight
for the rights of people with
disabilities in the post-covert era i'm
wondering how you concretely see policy
changing in europe for people with
disabilities
the crisis has been particularly hard
for the most discriminated and
disadvantaged members of society i'm
thinking now of of older people those
with disabilities ethnic minorities
those forced to live in many instances
in in isolation and with insufficient
access to necessary basic social and
health care services as well as women
and children and
sexual and gender minorities that are
increasingly becoming victims of
domestic violence we said the pandemic
has amplified the existing
obstacles and and inequalities and of
course this brought about major
consequences for people with
disabilities for instance in certain
member state basic awareness campaigns
on how to protect yourself and your
family from covet 19 were not accessible
to
persons with with disabilities for
instance the deaf and the blind people
so this put a spotlight on the weak
spots in our health systems so this is
why especially in the aftermath of the
pandemic it is essential to take
resolution so that persons with
disabilities can enjoy their human
rights and and fundamental freedoms and
participate in society and the economy
on equal basis with with others
commissioner i'd like to ask you about
the eu platform of diversity charters
that you're encouraging employers across
the eu to sign up to what's the need for
them what's the rationale behind them
societies that value this diversity are
are happier and benefit from this
diversity so would each diversity
initiative comes more progress more
commitment and and more determination to
to create this this union of equality
and these charters really really help in
embracing diversity and appreciating uh
diversity as a strength the opposite of
this is discrimination
discriminating against people whom we
consider to be different but that
stifles the potential
of
people so what has been the response of
people so far because you talked about
the importance of society embracing
diversity is society indeed embracing
diversity to your satisfaction
considering these charters
the charters are helping but no not
diversity is not embraced to my
satisfaction there's still so much we
need to do and that is why the charters
are
important the charters have been in
place for more than 10 years now and
today we have more
than
12 000 signatories representing over 16
million of employees all over the eu
examples of good practices introduced by
diversity charter signatories include
for instance the implementation of
flexible hours to to allow for better
work life balance
and increase in the recruitment of
people with disabilities and investment
and building up their skills and most
importantly i would say that diversity
charters are a valuable asset in
fighting discrimination and promoting
equality at work and this gives a
company the edge to attract uh talents
because they tell the world that they
will
recognize and value them fairly
thank you commissioner and do please
stay with us now what's it like for
people with disabilities in the
workplace or seeking work targeting a
career or a sector where their
disability could be a barrier we're
joined now by muriel bertrand a belgian
woman who works in human resources and
accounts and is deaf
so she's signing her answers to our
questions by video to an interpreter
aline whose voice you'll be hearing
muriel thanks a lot for coming on the
show
from your own experience give us please
an example of the kind of barriers
people with disabilities face in the
world of work
many managers don't know what
compensation payments are available for
employing disabled people
and it's true that in the media when we
think about informing people about these
payments
there's a lot of work to do here to make
managers more aware of all these
possibilities
okay so the media has a role in your
view but what can be done at a
regulatory level to improve the position
of people with disabilities
you know in public service organizations
there is an obligation to employ a
minimum number of people with
disabilities three percent or
thereabouts
so that's the situation in the public
service
but this standard is not respected or
obligatory in the private sector or in
ngos
and i think that obliging private
companies and ngos to recruit someone
with a disability is important
fundamentally what's your message to the
europe calling community on this
international day of people with
disabilities
we are all human beings we all want the
same rights and the same possibilities
it's also important to consider that for
deaf people
you don't see our disability it's not
obvious just by looking at us
blind people you notice their disability
immediately same thing with a wheelchair
user
but for deaf people it's not obvious
but what i really want to say is that
many deaf people have strong
competencies in the workplace
many thanks to you muriel and you arlene
for your interpretation
now commissioner helena dally back to
you
independent living is a major issue for
people with disabilities and it's
something that you've put at the heart
of your mandate what's your approach to
this and what can the commission
actually do
we are saying we want to move away from
institutionalization we want more
community living so
we shall present the framework to
improve service delivery for persons
with disabilities and next year we will
also issue a care strategy to to address
both carers and and care receivers um
from child care to um
to long-term care also the the
commission will support national
regional and
local authorities in their efforts to
provide the conditions for independent
living including through funds
available under the recovery and
resilience facility
living conditions are one thing but as
we've just heard from muriel
working conditions and opportunities are
quite another and whether you succeed or
fail will ultimately tell us a lot about
the kind of society europe really is
there is considerable um potential to
increase employment amongst persons with
disabilities if you encourage the
potential if you help people reaching
their
full potential that is not only the
moral argument of fairness and that
everybody must get a chance in in life
there's also the economic argument that
member states will be using more talent
they're using more potential which right
now we are throwing away
because we discriminate against people
with with disabilities
let's talk about a giant pillar in this
commission's program and that's the
green transition and how it intersects
with the lives of people with
disabilities in their everyday reality
what are you hoping to achieve
the green transition offers a unique
opportunity to rethink our living spaces
and mobility to make them more inclusive
and accessible and in this way to make
society truly inclusive for everyone so
we really should take this opportunity
for instance in in the context of
renovations to improve the energy
performance of buildings accessibility
barriers for persons with disabilities
should be removed so you do that all in
in one go another example
is investing in sustainable transport
systems and infrastructure that at the
same time
take into consideration the needs of
persons with disabilities thank you
commissioner we haven't quite finished
with you yet so please stay with us a
bit longer
paul let's talk to gordon rattray now
who uses a powered wheelchair after
suffering a spinal cord injury more than
20 years ago gordon is a scot and works
in the international relations
department of the european disability
forum not surprisingly perhaps he has no
complaint about conditions for people
with disabilities at his workplace but
what gordon have you seen elsewhere in
your daily outside contacts
no matter how much your current employer
removes the barriers the direct barriers
that you might face
to carry out your job within all their
powers
the minute you step out of that
zone and you start collaborating with
other agencies who may not be as clued
up about it
then then you start to face those
barriers all over again
gordon what is the most important
practical change in workplace policies
and practices you'd like to see
physical accessibility it's it's steps
everywhere you go there are there are
steps and there are stairs and there are
lifts that don't work and there are
doors that are too narrow and lots of
physical uh access barriers like this
but that's only talking about my very
specific situation and obviously
accessible bathrooms i mean this is a
crucial one that people generally don't
talk about but have
to know that wherever you go for a
meeting that there is going to be um
yeah an accessible bathroom and
accessible toilet i mean this is crucial
stuff it's basic stuff and when you
drill down or
when you actually pull it all together
maybe the most important thing to change
um is always attitude it's it's about
having the people who
have the power to make the changes and
realizing
uh a their obligations their legal
obligations to make the changes and be
the the big benefits that are there for
them if they do make the changes then
things start to happen
what policy making on workplace
practices at a national or eu level
would you like to see with regard to
people with disabilities
if we're talking about policymakers at
national and eu level then we're talking
at a fairly high level
and what they are obliged to do is to
adhere to their obligations under the un
convention on the rights of persons with
disabilities the crpd
and article 27 of the crpd talks about
work and employment
and it basically you know in its
simplest form it talks about applying
equality and non-discrimination to all
aspects of employment and that can mean
equal pay it can mean equal access to
vocational training can mean
career advancement equal opportunities
for promotion for maintaining work for
returning to work
and what do you think the international
day of people with disabilities should
mean for society when you've got
properly diverse workforce that reflects
the diversity of society
everything works better you know
companies perform better organizations
are are better places to work
many thanks gordon rattray for taking
the time to talk to us commissioner
we've a few more questions and then we
will genuinely let you go over to you
paul and go easy i will do my best
stephen commissioner we've been talking
about your views on disability and
diversity in a modern europe and your
targets as commissioner for equality now
we like a bit of a personal insight the
woman behind the title if you like the
next questions that we're going to put
don't need necessarily long answers just
first reactions yes or no even so here
we go
do you miss being an mp in malta your
home country no but i miss being a
minister
not an mp
has enough attention being paid to
children's mental health during and
after covert
no not only to children's mental health
even to the mental health of adults in
fact we are speaking about it now when
we are seeing
a lot of depression a lot of suicide
attempts so that's a reflection that we
did not pay enough attention
in a word okay maybe just a few what
inspires your engagement in human rights
justice injustice discrimination that i
see around me and i've always since i
was 16 years old i've always been
intrigued by this of by the treatment
which people have because they are
perceived to be
different and that is the reason why i
entered politics
what's your favorite book of all time
to kill a mockingbird i harperly
and what's your bedtime reading at the
moment i'm not talking about policy
papers or college meeting minutes
yes that's quite exhausting i'm reading
a very good book right now called
sorrow and bliss by by meg mason it's
it's how humor
can be used to mask one's
sad reality yeah it's it's it's a you
know
psychological philosophical so it's i'm
enjoying it
and the music you wind down to
well it depends on my mood
i can go from
i don't know rolling stones david bowie
and um you know that i like that kind of
music but it depends a lot on my mood
pink floyd i like a lot
and i like queen
you know so
okay so whose portfolio in the
commission would you like if you didn't
have yours
european green deal to merman's
portfolio
and does he know that
well i think he knows
commissioner thanks very much indeed for
running through a few of your favorite
things and themes it's been a pleasure
to have you on europe calling so thanks
for joining us thank you
well that's it from us now we'll be back
early in the new year with another
edition of europe calling profiling
another commissioner their work their
views and their passions you can tune
into previous editions on the dg comm
website and all good podcast platforms
and this edition will also be available
with subtitles and sign language
interpretation on the commission's
youtube page
for now enjoy the run-up to the festive
season from all of us on the team me
steven jones and me paul anderson
goodbye started with a virus so small
your eyes couldn't see it this is about
providing future for humanity
the commission has decided to find
google 4.34
billion euros
is europe's man on the moon moment we
are innovating here and we hope that you
like it
[Applause]
[Music]